notre plateforme conservatrice est plein
de mesures concrètes qui vont aider les
familles canadiennes à épargner et à
planifier pour l'avenir
un dieu scheer promet un crédit d'impôt
pour le transport en commun
le chef conservateur soutient qu'en
rendant le transport en commun plus
abordables les conservateurs espère
encourager plus de canadiens et
canadiennes à prendre l'autobus le métro
et le tramway ce qui réduira le nombre
de voitures sur les routes et les
émissions ici ou paie un crédit d'impôt
va rentrer le transport en commun plus
abordable mais si on se fie au passé la
mesure fiscale ne va pas encourager plus
de canadiens à prendre l'autobus ou le
métro 1 2 chez vous propose une mesure
fiscale qui existait sous l'ancien
gouvernement de stephen harper propose
une taxe l'efficacité de ce crédit
d'impôt a été analysé par la chaire de
recherche en fiscalité et en finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
conclusion cette mesure fiscale n'a pas
fait augmenter l'achalandage dans le
transport en commun aux pays de 2006 à
2010 est malgré ce crédit d'impôt
le nombre de véhicules par habitant a
grimpé de 11% au canada et le nombre
d'enfants perdus dans la circulation n'a
cessé d'augmenter un peu partout au pays
le nombre de travailleurs qui consacrent
au moins une heure à se rendre au
travail a augmenté de 5% entre 2011 et
une période durant laquelle le crédit
d'impôt pour le transport en commun
était pourtant disponibles